Well, it
is my
honor to be
back at the Munich Security Conference.
As many of us remember
last year on this stage
I warned of the imminent invasion
of Ukraine by Russia.
And let us all recall
Many at the time wondered
how we would all respond.
Many wondered, could Russia be stopped?
Would need to come together?
Would Natal break apart?
And would Ukraine
be prepared
Colleagues
today, a year later, we know
he is still standing.
Russia
Russia is weakened.
The transatlantic alliance is stronger.
Than ever
And most importantly,
the spirit of the Ukrainian
people indoors
and under.
Joe Biden, president of the United States
Our country has demonstrated
decisive leadership.
As President Biden often says,
the United States will support Ukraine
for as long as it takes.
We will not waver.
And today
at this Munich security conference,
I will then describe what we all continue
to have at stake.
The moral interest,
the strategic interest, and the reason
Ukraine matters
for the people of America.
For the people of Europe
and for people around the world.
First, from the starting days
of this unprovoked war, we have witnessed
Russian forces engage in horrendous
atrocities and war crimes.
Their actions are an assault
on our common values.
An attack on our common humanity.
And let us be clear.
Russian forces have pursued a widespread
and systemic attack
against a civilian population
Gruesome acts of murder,
torture, rape
and deportation.
Execution style killings,
beatings
and electrocution.
Russian authorities
have forcibly deported hundreds
of thousands of people from Ukraine
to Russia,
including children
They have cruelly separated
children from their families.
And we've all seen the images
of the theater in Mariupol,
where hundreds of people were killed
Think of the image
of the pregnant mother
who was killed
following a strike
at a maternity hospital
where she was preparing to give birth
Think of the images of Boucher
civilians shot
in cold blood.
Their bodies left in the street
The jarring photograph of the man
who was riding his bike
Think of the four year
old girl
who the United Nations recently reported
was sexually assaulted
by a Russian soldier.
A four year old child
Barbaric
and inhumane.
Long before
I was vice
president of the United States,
I spent the majority of my career as
a prosecutor.
Beginning as a young
lawyer in the courtroom
and later
running the California
Department of Justice,
I know firsthand
the importance of gathering facts
and holding them up against the law.
In the case
of Russia's actions in Ukraine,
we have examined the evidence
We know
the legal standards
And there is no doubt
these are crimes
against humanity.
The United States
has formally determined
that Russia has committed crimes
against humanity.
And I say
to all those
who have perpetrated these crimes
and to their superiors
who are complicit in these crimes,
you will be held
to account
in the face of these
in disputable facts.
To all of us,
here in Munich.
Let us renew
our commitment
to accountability
Let us renew our commitment
to the rule of law.
As for the United States,
we will continue to support
the judicial process in Ukraine
and international investigations
because justice must be served
Let us all agree
on behalf of all the victims,
both known and unknown
Justice must be served
Such
is our moral interest
We also have a significant
strategic interest.
The fight in Ukraine
has far reaching global
ramifications
No nation
is safe in a world where one country
can violate
the sovereignty and territorial integrity
of another
Where crimes against humanity
are committed with impunity.
Where a country
with imperialist ambitions
can go unchecked.
Our response to the Russian invasion
is a demonstration of our collective
commitment
to uphold international rules and norms,
rules and norms which, since the end of
World War Two,
have provided
unprecedented security and prosperity
not only for the American people,
not only for the people of Europe,
but people around the world.
Principles that state,
that sovereign nations have a right
to peacefully exist,
that borders must not be changed
by force,
that they are inalienable human rights,
which governments must respect,
and that the rule of law
must be preserved
Indeed, this moment
has tested our willingness
to defend and uphold
these rules and norms,
and we have remained strong
and we must stay strong
because if Putin were to succeed
with his attack
on these fundamental principles,
other nations
could feel emboldened
to follow his violent example
Other authoritarian powers
could seek
to bend the world to their will
through coercion.
Disinformation, and even brute force.
The international order
upon which we all rely
could be at risk
So in the interest
of global security and prosperity,
one of our defining missions
is to uphold
international rules based order.
And nations around the world agree
Consider more than 140 countries
voted at the United Nations to condemn
Russia's aggression and to support
Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity.
In defense
of the core principles of the U.N.
Charter.
Of course, we have also seen
nations like North Korea and Iran
send weapons in support
of Russia's brutal war.
We are also troubled that Beijing
has deepened its relationship with Moscow
since the war began.
Looking ahead,
any steps by China
to provide lethal support to Russia
would only reward aggression,
continue the killing,
and further undermine a rules based order
Again, the United States
will continue
to strongly support Ukraine,
and we will do so for
as long as it takes
the American people.
You see
in all
of the resolve of the people of Ukraine,
in all of their resilience
and righteousness
their willingness to fight
for freedom and liberty,
and the extraordinary tenacity
and leadership of President Zelensky.
In fact, joining me in Munich
are distinguished members
of the United States Congress,
Republicans and Democrats, members
of the House of Representatives
and the United States Senate.
And they are here together
because they understand the stakes.
The leadership of these members
has been vital
to America's support of Ukraine.
And President Biden
and I know that their support for Ukraine
will continue.
We also know
Ukraine will continue to be supported
by a United Transatlantic community
so that he could divide.
Remember where we were a year ago
In this, he has failed.
The NATO alliance is stronger
now than ever before.
And the United States commitment
to NATO's
and to its Article five is ironclad.
Just look at our track record
over the past year.
Just look
at our multilateral cooperation.
Together, we have provided
historic assistance to Ukraine.
Together, we have dealt
Russia a strategic failure.
Together, we have imposed
unprecedented costs on Russia.
And together,
we have pursued energy security
and reinvested in our collective defense.
And we have come together
to stand for our common values
and our common interests
and our common humanity.
I have no doubt
that this unity will endure.
I also have no illusions
about the path forward
There will
be more dark days in Ukraine.
The daily agony of war will persist.
The global ripple effects
will continue to be felt
by countries near and far from Africa
to Southeast Asia.
To the Caribbean.
But if Putin thinks he can wait us out,
he is badly mistaken.
Time is not on his side.
To be sure,
Ukrainians will continue
to be tried and tested
just as they have been over this past
year.
Transatlantic unity
will continue to be tried and tested
and I am certain that Ukraine
will rise to the task
that the United States and Europe
So my last point
America will continue our leadership
in defense of human dignity,
in defense of rules and norms
and in defense of freedom and liberty.
There is
too much at stake
to do anything less.
Americans know well
the meaning of independence.
We believe in the fundamental importance
of sovereignty and rule of law.
And we will always stand
on the side of justice.
Colleagues,
I do believe we all know
when future generations
look back at this moment,
they will see
that we understood
the task before us
and Rose to this occasion
And so to you, I say
the United States of America is proud
to be your partner in this noble pursuit.
Thank you.
Wonderful.
We got
and the vice president.
Thank you for this very,
very strong speech,
this commitment to transatlantic unity
this commitment to the support
of Ukraine.
And we have many, many representatives
from Ukraine here in the room.
And they
certainly were reassured by what you
have said. Let me ask you
you confirmed this U.S.
support, but we all know next year
the United States will enter
into an election campaign
and we are in a democracy.
We know which side of the aisle
the result will be.
How sure are you that certain?
Are you that what you have said, that
Putin, who wants to wait us out.
That in the end he will not succeed
Thank you, Christoph.
As I said,
I believe
and I believe the American people
understand the stakes
and the stakes being
our moral interest
and our strategic interest.
I will tell you, I travel around
the United States and I have seen
the Ukrainian flag fly in places
most of you
have probably never heard of
in the United States.
And storefronts
in front of homes,
people proudly
wearing, Americans proudly
wearing the colors of Ukraine,
The American people
are aware of the images of Bush.
The American people take great pride
in a fight for independence.
That being part of the foundation of
our nation.
And and our principles and values.
I think about where the United States
is going on this issue based on the track
record of where we've been.
You only have to look at where we were a
year ago
and where we are today
in terms of the contributions
and resources
that America has put into
everything from ammunition
to artillery to air defense,
from Stingers, to to Abrams tanks,
high Mar's javelins.
I look at it in the context of
the United States Congress,
which is here in force.
I'm told it is the largest delegation,
bipartisan, bicameral
of the United States Congress
to this meeting, to this
Munich Security Conference,
and how
forward the United
States Congress in a bipartisan way
has been in terms
of the track record of our support
just over the last year.
Not to mention in a it's a technical term
called an omnibus
in our budgetary processes.
But at the end of last year,
dedicating another $45 billion
for this upcoming year
to support Ukraine
Our priority is to ensure
Ukraine's strength on the battlefield.
And that is our commitment.
And it is a commitment
not only to the people of Ukraine,
but it is a commitment to our values
and the principles
we hold dear as a nation.
And I cannot be here
without also mentioning
the importance of the alliance, Europe
and what it has done.
Our host, Germany.
I was with Chancellor Schultz yesterday.
What we collectively have done.
We are not only joined,
I think, by our values
and our understanding of the stakes
and what is at stake
in terms of a moral
and a strategic interest.
We have been great colleagues
in terms of pooling our resources,
coordinating our resources,
in a way
that I believe
will give Ukraine the best support
they need to fight this fight.